vu de l'extérieur l'immeuble n'a
vraiment rien d'excitant
vu de l'intérieur non plus ce qui est
excitant sont ses occupants comme norme
michel villeneuve 79 ans pourquoi deux
portes parce que cet espace c'est l'une
des 40 salles de répétition insonorisé
que contient l'immeuble chômeurs at il
vraiment besoin d'un lieu à insonoriser
[Musique]
c'est un batteur de jazz une carrière de
plus de 60 années où il a tout fait y
compris survivre un cancer batteur il a
toujours voulu devenir enfin il faut
mais créer notre métier open son
économie il reçoit de batteries en
cadeau à 14 ans et trois ans plus tard
il commence sa carrière professionnelle
à montréal
et ce n'était pas les endroits pour se
produire qui manquait à montréal les
années 50 60 sont des années fastes pour
les musiciens les danseurs
il ya une multitude de cabarets bars et
restaurants avec spectacle c'est normal
on ne va toujours baigné dans la musique
il vient de saint henri où il a suivi
des cours de piano avec daisy pietersen
la soeur d'oscar pietersen son premier
contre 1 17 ans il joue dans un ensemble
avec un trompettiste choc pidgin le
frère de ce quart pietersen
vous connaissez le pianiste oliver jones
the jazz man né dans le quartier de la
petite bourgogne
maintenant vous reconnaissez aussi sur
batteur
est ce que vous ne savez pas c'est que
phil neville jones son cousin cousin par
la mer d'oliver jones
ils ont joué ensemble pendant des années
en tournée et à montréal bene norman
marché du neuf a aussi accompagné
plusieurs grands de l'époque qui était
de passage à montréal le saxophoniste
alto new york jackie mclean
des noms que l'on ne connaît plus
charlie rose saxophone ténor ou alors
beaucoup aux veines
tous ces américains qui venaient jouer
dans les boîtes montréalaise un son qui
nous donnait le goût de pleurer
tellement c'était beau dit villeneuve
mais le vent tourne dans les années 70
les boîtes de nuit ferment les unes
après les autres
le jazz de cabaret ne sont plus au goût
du jour lassana notaire il en sidaner
mois fbi a notamment tué à liker voile
et du montréal de cette époque il reste
peu de documents d enregistrement
parfois comme ce spectacle de duke
ellington au jazz hot de la casa loma
rue sainte catherine
un autre club célèbre des airs disco
dans les années 70 mais ça a longtemps
été une boîte de jazz très couru il n'y
avait aucun enregistrement de jazz aux
roquettes par rodez
jusqu'à ce que normalement charles
villeneuve retrouve dans ses affaires
des bandes qui l'avait lui même
enregistré grâce à un sociaux
financement de 5000 $ il a pu produire
deux cd avec des pièces enregistrées à
toronto et au racket en 63
[Musique]
un baril de bière en fût un coussin des
bâtons et la même bonne vieille batterie
acheté il ya 50 ans il est prêt à donner
un spectacle au b2 un des rares clubs de
jazz de montréal
c'est le lancement officiel de ses deux
albums
[Musique]
mais bien
[Applaudissements]
normes et d'un champ des 9 62 ans de
carrière et toujours ce même grand
plaisir de se produire devant lui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]